là on l'a vu dans les manifestations
quand on compare les mesures sanitaires
annoncé par le primat catholique avec
l'étoile jaune avec la shoah c'est une
insulte à la mémoire de ceux qui ont
subi la barbarie nazie et moi ça m'a
profondément choqué ça a choqué tout le
monde est évidemment et on l'a dénoncé
sur ce plateau
mais là on parlait plus de violence de
violences physiques et les permanents
gens venaient aux permanences d'élus
c'est quand même inadmissible quand on
touche à un élu en touche un des lieux
la république c'est une banalité de le
dire mais il faut tout simplement le
rappeler et je pense que healy a
aujourd'hui des personnels et
personnalités politiques pardon
d'extrême gauche et d'extreme droite qui
jettent de l'huile sur le feu avec des
polémiques totalement indigne en fait
ils maquillent leurs critiques sur le
pass sani tendance est là qui pour être
extrêmement concret je pense à nicolas
dupont aignan par exemple je pense
également dans une certaine mesure à
jean luc mélenchon qui n'en sommes pas
qu'ils ne tiennent pas des propos de
nature à apaiser le débat politique et
qui politise complètement un acteur
encore une fois que je le répète est
complètement scientifique un acte tout
simplement de se vacciner on est dans la
france des lumières dans la france de
pasteur oui moi je crois en relation si
je crois en le progrès et je crois en la
recherche est donc en fait sous prétexte
de critique et de spas sanitaire en fait
il se moque des libertés individuelles
ça n'est pas vrai ils s'en prennent à
macron en surfant sur les
mécontentements qui lie actuellement les
habits du président de la république et
c'est là où je trouve qu'il est
important de décorréler complètement les
de la politique du scientifique faire
d'abord la politique c'est d'abord et
avant tout une affaire de comportement
quand au plus haut niveau de l'état on
insulte on provoque on tient des propos
extrêmement les propos tenus par gabriel
à talons étaient quand même extrêmement
violent je trouve on n'avait pas besoin
de ça dans un pays qui mérite d'être
rassemblés et d'être unis pour lutter
contre cette crise donc déjà de donner
l'exemple de ne plus faire le maillot
nike qui a parlé de cynisme et d'égoïsme
de la part de certains manifestants
c'est ça que dénoncer un oui absolument
et donc quand j'entendais certains est
allé au delà il a parlé il avait été
plus met en garde aux normes et les
gaulois réfractaires tout ça on a on a
quand même à l'oreille qui résonne
certains propos du président de la
république et donc ils sont souvent dans
la provocation et parfois un peu je dois
le dire dans la morgue dans la façon
dont la tonalité des propos qui sont
tenus
ça provoque ce genre aussi de
radicalisation dans le comportement de
ceux qui sont anti vaccins et donc si on
pouvait un peu modérer revenir un peu
plus de modestie parce que oui ce virus
est imprévisible
on s'adapte et autres est clair
permanence et je terminerai juste en
vous disant une chose c'est que quand on
parle de dictature sanitaire moi je dis
que tout ce qui sent que employer ce
terme là sont des abrutis
voilà j'ai pas honte de l'assumer sont
des abrutis considère que nous ne sommes
plus dans un pays de liberté qu'ils
aillent en biélorussie en iran en chine
et je ne parle même pas de la corée du
nord
voyez donc on a des excès des deux côtés
donc moi ce que je souhaite c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on soit dans un débat
apaisé le moins fracture est possible et
que le président son porte-parole
prennent aussi leurs responsabilités
pour essayer de calmer les choses